He has come down through history as America's first serial killer,
the incarnation of pure evil.
He was the first of a new breed of American celebrity,
the handsome,
debonair,
superintelligence mass murderer is legends fields by his own insatiable
appetite,
for exaggeration,
would turn him into a monster.
The arch fiends of the age and the greatest criminal of this expiring century is
murder.
Castle situated at the heart of the world's greatest exhibition was reputedly.
The scene of unspeakable horror is yes.
The truth about Dr. h Dot h Holmes is far removed from the sensationalism that
surrounds his name.
No one did more to turn the gossip into legend than Holmes himself,
which makes it all the more difficult to get the truth about the devil in the
white city.
I was born with a devil in me.
I could not help the fact that I was a murderer more than a poet's can help the
inspiration to sing
who
would come to call himself.
Henry Howard homes was born with a far less impressive name,
and that was webster mudget on the 16th of May,
18,
61 in Gill Manson,
New Hampshire.
By all accounts,
his parents were upright and respectable people with the child's upbringing,
being pretty unremarkable.
Laser stories that his father was a violent alcoholic.
He would smother his children with chloroform,
so handkerchiefs to you,
teach them a lesson.
Are the results of a newspaper writers overactive imagination?
Yeah.
There is one incident in his youth which clearly did have a profound impact on
his later life when he was about 13,
two older boys dragged them into the local doctor's office.
I play Simon,
was terrified of because of the various tales had been told about body parts
lying around the place.
The bullies brought the terrified by face to face with a human skeleton,
but rather than frightening him,
human bones,
they fascinated the trials,
this fascination.
It grew into an adult desire to study medicine,
homes out another really fascination,
and that was with women by the age of 16.
He was working odd jobs when he fell head over heels in love with a beautiful
young woman by the name of fire and the mets,
Clara while working on her father's farm soon after they were both at a church.
Social Clara though,
while she was flirting with another boy,
and this made young Herman see reds,
he promptly marched.
Every other boy bands threatened to punch his lights out if he didn't.
Gala last well,
this thing to impress young Clara with Herman,
escorting her home arm in arm.
The next day.
He was telling everyone that they were engaged.
The two,
both 17 years of age at the time were married by a justice of the peace on
fourth of July,
18,
78 for the first six months of the marriage.
It was kept a secret with a couple living apart with their parents when it was
finally revealed farlands mother or Riley commented she couldn't have done much
worse and we'll probably have to support you as father arranged for her to work
in his brother's grocery store in east concourse.
Nine months later,
Clara she gave birth to a son named Robert.
Becoming a father.
Seems to have inspired him in because he was interested in medicine.
He quit the store on Wednesday to take up an apprenticeship under Dr. Right.
The owner of the office in which had been introduced to the skeleton six years
previously,
ballroom and the baby went to live with our parents.
Yeah.
The budding medical took up more formal studies at the medical school in
Burlington,
Vermont.
During this time.
He conducted himself as a single man.
In fact,
he carried on a relationship with the daughter of his landlord.
Lives became so passionate that people thought they were engaged.
When Hammond's remade,
Fred ingles revealed to the girl's father,
but he was already married.
The two time that lead a thrashing on Ingolstadt left him with a black eye and
scratched face.
Darker than this though was the fact that the wife of the owner of the boarding
house once noticed a foul smell emanating from Herman's room on investigating.
She was horrifying to find a dead baby under his bed.
His explanation was that had been experimenting with dissections is part of his
homework.
Herman was warms.
Do never bring dead bodies into the house again it to how many wins an audit to
study at the University of Michigan at this time,
he took his wife and son with him,
but the marriage,
while it was already on shaky grounds,
other residents of the boarding house,
but they live in later records that the couple often quarrels with Clara
frequently sporting black eyes.
At some point cholera.
Mr decided she had enough because she returns home with her baby then marriage.
Well,
it was effectively over,
but this would never be formalized now on infested by family home and threw
himself into his studies.
He was particularly fascinated with the dissection of human bodies.
Nothing,
nothing more than the country's Wayne's of flesh and pull out body organs.
One small and he took to taking home infant corpses to work on during the spring
break.
This fellow students remembered that harmon's fascination with dissection.
Well,
it was unnatural mender nerving,
but then there's the question of whether or not Hammond participated in a ruse
of faking someone's death in order to collect insurance money and is very
dubious.
Autobiography.
He claims that he and his medical student pals spoke of the idea but never
actually did it and given his pension for self exaggeration,
it seems unlikely he would have been shy about revealing this v one scandal from
his college days,
which can be substantiated as involves not surprisingly,
are women though still married to Clara.
He began courting the women in his boarding house.
He resided.
He had promised to marry her.
The new women found the letter in his room that was signed by his wife.
This certainly shocked to women,
but she should have counted ourselves.
We're lucky at least she didn't find a dead baby.
Nevertheless,
the women complained to the medical school faculty citing breach of promise.
Payment appeared at a hearing and themes that woman was lying and that he never
promised to marry her heart.
The faculty believed him and he was acquitted.
A few months later on being handed his graduation diploma,
though harmon approached his professor and said Dr. focused things that women
said about me on twitter
after graduating and lived with his family back in New Hampshire during the
summer.
That wasn't.
He began working as both a physician and a school teacher in New York.
During this time,
he gains a reputation as a debt default and a womanizer.
He proposed marriage to to more women that with the latter mini Everett's
backing out with a prophetic reflection,
there is something lacking in that man's character that time will reveal.
I do not like him.
I firmly believe that he would commit murder.
Herman also acquired a reputation as a swindler.
He wouldn't use any number of excuses to get out of paying his rent.
In the end,
he left town in the middle of the night in order to escape a mountain of debt,
even swindled the price of his train ticket out of town.
It was may of 18,
66 and that swindled train ticket and taken him to Chicago.
It was his intention to find work in a drug store,
but he needed a pharmacy license.
In order to do that.
You went to Springfield and sat a three day examination.
It was subsequently announced in the press that Harry h homes passed the bar.
This announcement is it marks the first time that the home's alias was used,
why he chose to call himself Harry Howard.
Homes is still unknown,
contrary to what many people think.
It's not a nod to sherlock holmes,
Conan Doyle's most famous creation would not appear for yet another year almost
christened as new name by becoming a big ernest on the way to Chicago.
He spent time in Minneapolis where he took up with and then married a young
woman named Mirta belknap.
That's where she was rather plain looking,
but her parents had money and that was enough for homes.
Shortly after moving to Chicago,
he used this wealth to purchase a parcel of land on what was then 701 to 700 and
360,
third street and Englewood.
He had ownership but in zoo,
his wife's name,
and then into that if our mother,
in order to keep the credit as a bay almost mythology tells us that the bad
doctor needled his way into the employers are bedridden.
Pharmacist named e s Holton,
who's young wife was run off our feet,
operating the business by herself.
Homes was hard to take over the operation and shortly thereafter the couple
disappeared with the implication here being that homes murdered them,
but this isn't at all the reality of the situation.
Instead,
Dr. yes,
Holton,
whereas actually the wife or husband's rather than being on his deathbed was a
robust longshoreman.
Dr Olsen's are on homes and found him to be and the ideal asset for the
business.
When she became pregnant with our second child in 18,
87,
she decided to sell the pharmacy to homes rather than disappearing.
The holtons both lived well into the 20th century remaining in these same
neighborhoods.
That whole time the pharmacy business became a great success,
becoming especially popular with young women who came from afar to be served by
the charming,
handsome new doctor,
honestly begins eating on assistants who were invariably a nubile young beauties
who were flocking to Chicago by the train.
At the same time,
homes turns his attention to the vacant lot that he owned on the same street as
the pharmacy plan to construct a two story building with retail space on the
first floor and residential apartments on these seconds.
The building had some unusual features.
There was a hidden compartment between the first and second floors along with a
staircase between floors and that could only be reached from a trapdoor in the
second story buffering far more troubling than these designed quacks,
however,
was the fact that Holmes refused to pay his bills when the build is I've never
iron and steel sued in 18.
80 eight homes,
claimed at the team wasn't liable because the building was actually owned by his
mother in law when the building company lies began to chronicle his involvement
in the project homes alleged event,
one of the steel beams provided was too short,
which negated the entire contract.
Defending himself in court apparently did nothing to dwindle his passion for
swindling.
His favorite trick was buying goods on credit and then selling them for cash and
not paying the original bill.
In one case,
he purchased in this specialty heavy,
safe on credit and had it installed on the first floor of his new building.
Having balls bells around that.
When the repossession agents came knocking homes replied,
go ahead and take the safe,
but I warn you not to damage the building.
They're repossessing as they struggled for hours.
Finally realizing that they couldn't get it out without tearing down a wall.
They have no choice but to leave the safe exactly where it was.
The people who worked for homes single use to is quirky ways he wants invited to
work at do you step inside the safe and start yelling when homes close the door
in order to test if it was soundproof,
his housekeeper would also regularly catch tip toeing around at night and the
janitor who worked at the pharmacy records a time when homes showed him a
collection of fake beards and other discussions,
is it 1990,
almost decided to sell the drugstore business in order to focus on real estate.
Unsurprisingly,
the salads and into another swindle.
After the new owner took possession,
he was shocked to find that much of the floor stock had not been paid for with
repossession agents claiming them back still somehow managed to talk his way out
of this struggle.
In fact,
even though he no longer owns the drugstore,
he still spent a lot of time there.
He just so happened to be on hands.
One day when one of the new investors showed up with important information to
share the mend and inexplicably collapsed right outside the drug store.
Holmes was the first one to aside pouring a dark liquids down the man's throat.
Within minutes he was debt.
This was likely the first person to die at bands of Dr Holmes killed,
likely because he knew too much about the magic magic,
although we'll never really know what that information he had was in July of 18,
89 homes employed a young couple conant who worked in the pharmacy and lived on
the second floor of the recently completed anglewood building.
Within a month,
pons and Julia were engaged in a fat even as myrtle lived under the same roof.
This understandably drove a wedge between the couple with ned filing for divorce
and quitting homes as employee.
Julia now started doing tango herself in homes.
There's financial web enlisted our whereas the cofounder of a number of
businesses and took out numerous steps in our name.
Then on July the fourth,
19,
91,
Julia and say,
Reggie rolled daughter,
pearl disappeared off the face of the earth.
The body is whenever discovered and Tom's never confessed to murdering them,
but it seems quite likely that they were the victims if the deadly doctor around
this same time on started a brand new business and this the warner glass bending
company,
just the fact that he knew nothing about glass bending,
he convinced those who would listen,
that he had invented a unique gloss bending technique to perfect.
He had built a furnace in the basement of his two story building and made a
great show of setting to work though no one actually saw him.
That one,
the last
after the establishment of his basement furnace,
the disappearance of young women who came into homes is circle became more and
more frequent.
First there was emily,
instagrams.
You came to Chicago looking for work in May of 18,
92 homes,
employer as a typewriter girl,
and we're seeing getting much more for his money.
When the girl disappeared around Christmas time,
homes dismissed is with what became a common explanation.
She's gone to Europe to get married by the end of 18,
92.
The whole city of Chicago was a buzzword.
The prospect of the approaching welds fat in celebration of the 400th
anniversary of Columbus is landing on the America's.
Never want to pass up an opportunity.
Homeless quickly had a third story put onto his building to serve as a hotel.
However,
he never really intended to use the floor as a hotel.
The amount of homes could make renting out rooms were small potatoes compared
with water.
You could make a buying,
convincing others that he was opening a hotel with such a venture in the work so
you could raise money from investors who never see a penny back.
You can also find numerous goods on credits and sell them without paying for
them.
And then as a final windfall,
he decided to make thousands and insurance money by setting the building on
fire,
just like the popular notion that the hotel was flourishing during the welds
fan,
during countless women do that death.
They're all known records that he even took in a single paying customer when he
set the structure of blaze 18,
93 to claim the insurance,
the only people on the site where longterm residents,
the resulting claim would spend years going through the courts,
by which time the claimant's it'd be behind bars.
With balancing lawsuits,
Holmes decided that it was time to quit.
Chicago has traveled to countries
Lewis and finally to Philadelphia
along the way.
We got married once more this time to a 23 year old with a $2,000 in Harrison's.
He also fell in with a likeminded swindler by the name of Benjamin Quetzal
Pencil.
Old Lady got himself thrown in jail to passing bad checks and swanee was inside
almost began paying the premiums on the life insurance policy when he got out
the to joined forces and not just a vacant lot in Fort Worth.
Yeah,
they set about building a replica of the complex that Holmes had built and then
burned to the ground in Chicago,
just linked the original building,
the Texas hotel featured a number of strange passengers and twists,
but just what homes planning to do with a building is unclear.
He never hung around long enough to use it.
What he did do was take out tens of thousands of dollars on mortgages in it and
then disappear without making more than a couple of token payments for to move
to send the new as well on sport drugstore for the down payments of $50 and
promissory notes that are completely worthless.
What a surprise.
Had Ben approached a drugstore supply runs,
convinced him that he was interested in buying the drugstore from homes.
If that ends in the money,
he would then use them as their main supplier.
They agreed these winds,
although it came unstuck when the drugstores or app called in the next day only
to find the place,
shut it up.
It got suspicious and causing the authorities almost was arrested and he spent
three days.
Jay
on his release,
homesteaded for Philadelphia and that least Wyndell that would prove his
undoing.
Yeah,
he plans to make good on those insurance premiums.
Had paid for pf still a few months back.
The team then had long been scheming to defraud the fidelity mutual insurance
company by faking capsules,
deaf and splitting the proceeds in early September.
However,
cancel golf,
cold feet and wanted to back out,
and I'm happy homes agreed to meet up the next day to further discuss the issue.
When he turns up at Pitt source address,
homeless,
proceeded to get him drunk.
Then he knocked him out with chloroform handkerchief,
increasing his dosage into this old friend was debt homes,
then attempted to stage the scene to make it look like an accident.
Then we're this 23 year old wife into.
He jumped on the train for Indianapolis,
intends on securing the $10,000 insurance payout.
In the end,
the payoff was made to be at sols widow,
but homeless convinced her that her husband had died in $7,500 for the taxes
building.
She handed the money over as an active seeming graciousness.
Homes agreed to accompany in bps,
all children to Indianapolis where they were to stay with that arms before he
could deliver them.
However,
and he discovered that he was a wanted man.
Authorities from a number of states,
including Philadelphia
to him.
Okay.
Now officially on the run,
he moved the children all over the countryside.
At some point you decided that the children would have to die.
The youngest eight year old Howard was poisoned with cyanide while the two
girls,
but like he gassed to death.
The bodies were buried in a cellar by now.
Detectives were hot on homelessness trail.
They finally caught up with him in Boston and of all things arrested him for
horse staff's,
a raft of the charges followed and in October of 18,
95,
it was convicted of murdering Benjamin Quetzal Home,
subsequently confessed to 27 murders and was hanged on May the seventh,
18,
96.
His dying wish was for his body to be buried under 10 feet of concrete to
prevent grave robbers from stealing and dissecting his body.
A luxury which he denied many of his victims,
so I won't ask whether you enjoyed that video,
but I sure hope you found it interesting.
If you did,
please do hit that thumbs up button below.
Don't forget to subscribe.
We do two videos just like this,
focusing on some important person from history or present day everyday of the
week,
so two videos a week.
Hit subscribe your,
get those.
Do checkout some of the other videos that will link to on the screen now as well
as in the description below,
and as always,
thank you for watching.